اقتتموا اليوم في الرياضه اعماله المنتدى
الدولي للامن السيبراني بعد مشاركه واسعه
للمهتمين بهذا المجاري الحيوي الذين
يمثلون اكثر من 100 دوله المنتدى شهد حضور
شخصيه عالميه سياسيه بارزه كما حضر
الجلسات الحواريه وزير الطاقه السعوديه
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان ووزير
الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات المهندس عبد
الله السواحد
قاده سياسيون وخبراء في الامن السيبراني
من حول العالم اجتمعوا في المنتدى الدولي
للامن السيبراني في نسخته الثانيه الحضور
الكثيف من المهتمين والمختصين في دول
العالم يوضح الاهتمام الدولي بتعزيز الامن
السيبراني خاصه في قطاعات الطاقه والغذاء
هو تعزيز الامن ليس لدوله واحده فحسبه
فنحنون نتحدث عن مشاركه المعلومات والقبض
على المجرمين واستغلال قوه الامن لجمع
العالم معا واعتقد بان هذه محافظات
ايجابيه جدا لجميع الدول معا بدلا من
تفرقتها لا شك ان المنتدى اليوم من
المنتديات الرائده خصوصا اليوم قاعد نتكلم
عن مشاركه اكثر من 100 دوله ااه 120 متحدث
اكثر من 4,500 حاضر تقريبا 30 جلسه حواريه
كلها تناقش جميع القضايا الحساسه والمهمه
في مجال الامن السبراني وكلها تناقش اليوم
على المجال العالمي بجميع الافكار اللي
تسب في مجال الامن السبراني
مساعد وزير الدفاع للشؤون التنفيذيه خالد
البياري قال ان الدول بدات تستفيد من
التجربه السعوديه في الامن السيبراني في
اشاره لتقدم السعوديه الى المركز الثاني
عالميا في الامن السيبراني بعد امريكا
اعتقد التجربه في المملكه ثريه جدا في
المجال همم مركزه العمل من خلال الهيئه
همم حقيقه كان نموذج مميز همم
وكثير من الدول اعتقد قاعده تتعلم من ال-
ال- ال- التجربه المملكه همم
وجود هالوجود الهيئه وقدرتها على تنظيم
القطاع كان جدا مهم يساهم هذا المنتدى عبر
جلساته وشركاته في ايجاد حلول لتامين
الدول والقطاعات الخاصه لانظمتها
الالكترونيه وحمايتها سيبرانيا
في ظل هجمات سيبرانيه متزايده لا تقل
خطورتها عن الحروب الواقعيه
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه من المنتدى
الدولي للامن السيبراني ينضم الينا
المهندس عبد الرحمن الحسن نائب محافظ
الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني
للاستراتيجيه والتعاون الدولي مهندس عبد
الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض اولا لماذا المنتدى
الدولي للامن السبراني الحاجه له اليوم في
ظل وجود عدد كبير من المنتديات الاقليميه
تقنيه ودوليا ايضا
حياك الله اخوي نايف ومساء الخير لك
والاستاد المشاهدين الكرام طبعا للاجابه
على هذا السؤال هناك ثلاث عناصر اساسيه
ننظر لها العنصر الاول وانما يميز المنتدى
الدولي للامن السبراني هو وجود نظره
شموليه وواسعه على جميع القضايا المتعلقه
بالامن السيبراني وهذا نعتقد انه من خلاله
سيسهم في ملء وسد فراغ موجود على الساحه
العالميه لمعالجه القضايا الملحه والعاجره
في الامن السبراني النقطه الثانيه اخي
نايف ان المنتدى ليس فقط محصوره على
الجوانب التقنيه ذات الصله بالامن
السبراني وانما يتعدى هذا ليتناول قضايا
متعلقه بالجوانب الجيو السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وكذلك الانسانيه
ويتضح اخي نايف همم هذا عندما ينظر الى
برنامج
الدوري للامن السبراني وكذلك الشعار الذي
تم تصميمه له فنحن نتحدث عن شعار اعاده
الترتيبات في اعاده النظر في الترتيبات
السمرانيه العالميه وننظر في هذا الشعار
من خمسه محاور المحور الاول ينظر في
القضايا الجيوسيبرانيه وكذلك القضايا
الاقتصاديه متعلقه بالامن السبراني وايضا
مستقبل العمل السيبراني
وايضا الامن السبراني للجميع نقطه اخيره
فقط
ايضا عندما ننظر الى المتحدثين في هذا
المنتدى هناك 127 متحدث تقريبا اتوا من
مختلف التخصصات ومن مختلف الدول لمعالجه
وهمم النظر والتطرق بالموضوعات
الاستراتيجيه في الامن السبراني وهذا هو
حقيقه ما يميز المنتدى الدولي للامن
السبراني في وصف منصه عالميه تجمع الخبراء
في الامن السبراني بالحديث عن جمع الخبراء
عن هذه الجلسات عن النقاشات همم مع ختام
اليوم الثاني والاخير كيف وجدته ولمستوا
هذه النتائج للجلسات
للمخرجات لما تم في هذا المنتدى الدولي
ممتاز يمكن اخي نايف تلخيص هذه النتائج في
ثلاثه نقاط اساسيه النقطه الاولى ان هناك
اجماع دولي تقريبا من الخبراء المشاركين
في هذا المنتدى انه ل ل لبناء فضاء سبراني
امن وموثوق ان ان بناء الفضاء سبراني امن
وموثوق هو ركيزه اساسيه لتحقيق التنميه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وايضا تحقيق ااه
الرخاء لمستقبل الانسان النقطه الاخرى اخي
نايف ان التعاون الدولي بين الدول
والمنظمات والقطاع الخاص هو ركيزه اساسيه
لبناء فضاء سبراني امن وموثوق يمكن النمو
والازدهار حول العالم
ايضا استشعرنا اخي نايف اهميه همم وجود
منصه عالميه تجمع خبراء الامن السيبراني
وتنظر في القضايا الامن السبراني من بعد
استراتيجي مثل القضايا التي تطرق لها
المنتدى الدولي للامن السبراني هذا العام
سواء كانت قضايا سياسيه او اقتصاديه او
اجتماعيه او غيرها بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء
الله شكرا جزيلا لك انضمامك الينا في
نشرات الرابعه من المنتدى الدولي الى
الامن السيبراني المهندس عبد الرحمن الحسن
نائب محافظ للهيئه الوطنيه للامن
الاسبراني
للاستراجيه والتعاون الدولي شكرا جزيلا لك